what's up everyone we're at the cinema
center at marble at Tiff 2023 and I'm so
excited to talk about expats right now
Lulu huge congratulations I have
screened episode five of course and even
just from one episode alone the ambition
is off the charts and it really is
something else so huge congratulations
thank you so much thank you so I was
doing my homework and I know that
initially you passed on the project why
did you pass and then what change that
made you think it was worth making the
series commitment yeah you know I think
I initially passed because I was just so
intimidated by the scale of the project
and I really wanted to work with Nicole
Kidman I mean she's incredible I've been
a fan of her so many of her Works
um but I felt such a sense of
responsibility in depicting a place like
Hong Kong
um and the term expats comes with is
very loaded it comes with all all of
these connotations and it's like can I
handle that and all of the nuances that
comes with depicting
um the world of expat and other people
who are people of diaspora and um and so
that's why I passed intimidating
challenge a challenge that you seem to
have met so talking a little bit about
the journey from going from feature
filmmaking to making a series like this
can you maybe isolate one particular
learning curve that you had to go on
while adjusting to that format but then
also maybe something about making a
series that was more creatively
fulfilling for you than you ever could
have imagined yeah I have to say you
know as a writer and I'm a classical
pianist turned writer so I've very much
used to working alone and being quite
lonely and developing ideas but for this
project I had a writer's room and that
was incredible and just um so nourishing
for my soul to be able to work with
other women and to argue and disagree
but then also come to a place where we
could agree to disagree but then tell a
story through all of that it was
incredibly it was different and it's
completely changed the way that I look
at development of stories I love hearing
that this is going to sound like a weird
out of left field question but because
I'm at Tiff and I'm seeing a million
things some of the themes bleed together
and I was just covering Gonzo girl and
they have a character in that movie that
is dealing with loving and hating the
confines of his own earlier success and
of course we know you very well for the
farewell so it was making me wonder can
you maybe give me one misconception
about what it means to have a hit
feature and then move on to your next
project but then also something about
the success of the farewell that helped
you make expats and make it your way
yeah you know I um I wasn't expecting
the farewell to reach as many people as
it did and you know I think there's
always fears of
um there being lots of expectations and
then you know can I only do this one
thing
um that is so it was so personal it was
really based on my own life and I'm very
autobiographical and
um and so how do I tell other stories
that are still personal even though they
are not autobiographical and so those
were some of the questions that I was
asking and after
um you know promoting a movie you still
have to go and face a blank page and
that's why I was so grateful for the
writer's room to have this safe space
um that really felt like therapy
all right I have to go back to Nicole
Kidman now because of course she's been
involved with the project since the very
beginning she is also a star of the
series as well how does it change your
Dynamic with one of your actors when
they're involved to that extent in
addition to just playing a main role I
should take out the word just in
addition to playing on main role yeah
you know I think that it wouldn't have
been made without her and that is the
fact of it because
um we had my entire team my
collaborators from the farewell came
onto this project and we had done a very
small three million dollar feature about
my grandmother and to board something of
this scope and size and budget
um it was incredible that she believed
in my vision enough to help make sure
that I was supported by the studio and
they did and and
um I just couldn't believe it I know
making this your way was very important
to you and important to you making the
decision to commit having on through
this process and and gotten that what is
something you would recommend for
another filmmaker seeking the same thing
seeking that same support from a major
company and also the producers and other
people around them yeah I think it's
just really important to remember your
voice and that you're there for a reason
you know so often times you get brought
onto a project because people want you
and they want they've seen the work that
you've done and then when you're in the
middle of that you know it's important
to remind yourself of that like that you
know the thing that you did before is
what got you here and so you have to
keep doing that and don't let your fear
or you're being intimidated as I was
um change your process and make you
think that you need to do it like other
uh filmmakers before you you know you
can always find your way and carve your
own space and have your own process in
your own team within this industry it's
breaking my heart I have to let you go
in a minute but I wanted to make sure to
squeeze into more our questions one why
bring episode 5 to Tiff in particular
and did you ever consider screening the
pilot instead you know the first thing
that I said when I was talking to the
studio about this project was I am
really honored to do this series
um but the only way that I'll do it is
if I can make this episode five and it's
the first thing that I want people to
see and I would like to screen it at
festivals I mean that was really like my
entryway in because For Me growing up in
America as a Chinese immigrant that is a
big part of my identity and even though
I went back to Hong Kong as an American
expat which is a very different identity
I wanted there to be two doors into this
world and uh it's just been such a an
honor to have audiences at Tiff enter
this other door first I like the sound
of that what now I have to let you go
I'm gonna ask one more question though
because I was reading another interview
where you mentioned something to the
fact of you know always wanting to find
your voice even though you didn't think
you were going to go the series path you
wanted to do it to hone your voice in
the industry further so now having made
a series and come out the other side
what did you learn about your
storytelling Voice via that process yeah
I do have to say you know I had a lot of
imposter syndrome because I believe that
artists are made through their body of
work my mother used to always say to me
you know if you're 20 years old and you
write the greatest poems in the world
not sure if you're a poet you know but
if you're in your 60s and you've written
poetry your entire life even if you know
you don't have the biggest uh fan group
and you're not published you are a poet
and that always stuck with me and so I
think that
um having made expats now which is six
movies and having been on set for you
know 10 times the amount of days almost
that the farewell was shot in
um I definitely do feel a little bit
more like like a a director
I hate that I have to let you go a short
and sweet interview does not do this
production Justice we did not get to
talk about your incredible Ensemble
Beyond Nicole it is really something
else huge congratulations and I hope you
enjoy celebrating expansive thank you so
much thank you